[Music]
in Karoshi news portion submitted by
kobayashi-san a 31 year olds death Oh
from overwork causes Japan to rethink
its work-life balance really they need
to stop with that karo P [ __ ] because
people are overworking themselves and
they don't have a life that's when you
[ __ ] you know Sammy know when you
Sanrio store yourself - oh my god I
would love that I'm an adult now I stop
I'm probably too odd because people
gonna be like what school everyone else
Keroppi are you kidding me man
it still exists yes yes exist I'm still
a child go still my favorite new taco
here in OPEC was pretty good - hello
kitty she is the face I like much Mauro
anyways so who let the penguin yeah so
Karoshi
means I still heard Keroppi Karoshi
means death from overwork in Japanese Oh
actually have a term for that yeah and
so so recently this story has been
circulating a lot I'm not sure exactly
why because it's happened back in July
2013 but I guess is a topic that we're
talking about again and so this woman
she was 31 years old
new asado it was her name and she worked
for a jet for the Japanese views and
network called NHK and it was reported
that she logged in 159 overtime hours in
one month before she died of heart
failure you know why - I bet you she
died this because there's it's like you
think misogyny is Superman in America
you just wait till you work for a
[ __ ] Asian company like women have to
work [ __ ] four times as hard in Asia
but just because they number one they
get talked down to by the superiors and
on top of that they have to worry about
getting sexually harassed like it's not
one of those things worse like the guys
like being sly about it to like
literally they're like seeing sometimes
as lower beings because I know somebody
that worked for a Japanese company and
she wanted to [ __ ] die so she
switched over to a Korean company and
she said it was better which is kind of
weird his career pug puppies companies
are even even guys feel bad because
people that are older than you yeah look
at younger people as like sub lower
level beings - yeah I know this one
Japanese company that worked in
logistics and they had a bullying
problem there and I heard about it I
still applied because I needed a job and
then I but I didn't get a job there
I worked somewhere else and I heard that
somebody got bullied to death there he
was bullied so hard he he was found by
his wife hanging because bullying is a
problem and because it's like it's like
a frat house you know the way that they
I worked for a Japanese company but it
was actually Okinawan and they're like
the Hawaiians of Japanese they are but
they're still Asians like I think no
matter how chill you are Asians are
always gonna be a little bit more tense
than the rest you know just just yeah
it's the way that they do things why I
guess that's the the con to the pros
because I guess the pro is like there's
like there's a structure everywhere you
go no matter where it's like you plug
yourself in and everything still flows
good but then I guess that's the con
because I like Asian discipline like
don't get me wrong I think Asian
discipline is actually really great
because it teaches you respect it also
teaches you order but the problem with
that too especially in a lot of like
Korean companies - like you said the age
thing and like they'll hold or older
respect you're not allowed to speak on
it no matter how great your idea is it
matter so it's just like you could be
doing something wrong it's just because
that person's older than you he won't
speak up and it'll just keep on going
wrong how come how come you're my own
thing and you're always talking [ __ ] to
me well because [ __ ]
that's why that's the difference all
right you [ __ ] [ __ ] noona you're
touching me like that you [ __ ] Kazuki
oh my god oh my god you [ __ ] boot
that [ __ ] [ __ ] she called you
chocolate you know so I wrote I work I
won't hurt this very sweet birthday
thing on my Instagram thank you for that
much and I called her I put that and
then somebody was like you really
shouldn't call her oh my god I missed
your birthday wait weren't you there it
was take your party day I didn't say
happy birthday like to Gio like I always
post pictures on Instagram such pieces
of [ __ ] I did I know you guys are busy I
did not mind I thought that was that was
fun
Olli crying a little bit today's only
put you guys all posted Tyco and I think
that was better but I did cry a little
bit well you mean now you have to get
used to a girl once you have a kid
you're not important I said happy I did
you don't think it was two days late but
I was enjoying Hawaii
happy birthday Julie I forgot thank you
I was too busy sleeping that [ __ ] was so
funny Bart was like I pass can you be
there cuz I'm gonna bring out the cake
and stuff like that and then what a cake
was coming out from Tim bar forgot now
geo saw it first before I was standing
right there and then you're like what
the [ __ ] no it was funny since I started
singing happy birthday win it cuz you
saw me and I was like huh anyways back
to those whole overworking Japanese
things so there was no
this 31 year old oh no this 24 year old
woman named Matsui Takahashi and she
committed suicide on Christmas Day 2015
I'm logging in 105 hours and overtime in
just one month and mom looks just in
overtime yes only overtime yeah month
damn so if there's not 20 working days
in a month that's like four extra hours
a day of overtime she had tweeted before
her death she said it's 4:00 a.m. my
body is trembling I'm going to die I'm
so tired oh my goodness yes she died she
killed herself all she killed herself
this is a different woman Miz Liz in
2015 also too light you know people got
to realize not only is your physical
health important which I completely
ignore but I don't ignore my mental
health ever this right here has to stay
fresh but you know in Asian culture that
if you feel like you want to rest it's
drill to you that you're a [ __ ]
little [ __ ] that's not so [ __ ] up
just because it's like if you feel
discomfort and if you feel like you're
suffering and you need a break your your
top from a very little kid that you're a
[ __ ] little [ __ ] and you just work
harder I've heard that from all three of
you guys actually personal because this
is drill is this drill dead it's not no
way it's the way that we're raised I'm
just trying to put it out there so that
so that people couldn't like people can
hear your guys the story and be like
okay they've gone through it you know
they're talking about yeah they're
[ __ ] traumatized is because like
sometimes I want to take a break but my
brain says no I really wish though I
could apply that [ __ ] to the physical
activity sign just wasn't drilled in our
guy's head that part right that I can't
transfer it over I can do that with
[ __ ] any other thing that I'm doing
whether it's a business my channel
editing or if I I'll figure out a
[ __ ] way to do it but then when I
wake up in the morning and sometimes I
just watch Rocky right do you know what
I've seen you do though in basketball
when you're like I haven't played
basketball in eight months I'm out of
shape and I'm gonna just take it
children yeah I'm gonna take it
wrinkles an ass
no no David like working out is mainly
mental like you didn't transfer that
mentalness that I do with like let's say
figure out an ice cream recipe haha to
going to the gym he doesn't get any
reward I don't get that reward and I
want it though cuz I watched all these
like documentaries and it gets me I'm oh
look at these guys I'm suspending you
you're not gonna do because you do this
[ __ ] what kind of gay [ __ ] is first of
all this is not gay at all this is how
people found themselves when they're hot
and I'm getting heated right now I know
how you feel though cuz it wasn't till
recently that I started becoming a buff
guy mental beam it's hard though it's
rough man I want to take what you do
with the gym and apply it in my life but
that's not gonna happen
it isn't I think I think for both these
cases where it's both females I think
it's a double whammy for them I can't
really relate with the Asian mentality
but I can relate a little theme aside
cuz I'm sure like the way I was raised
it's like the women have like this this
duty to a pole to like maintain the
house and look presentable and like
you're [ __ ] everything has to be
spotless awesome so you just feel judged
all the time nobody cares clean geo and
in your mind you're like oh my god yeah
yeah yeah and in it so so I can only see
it from that female perspective that
just kind of traditionally raised that
way so now applying the Japanese and
then working in a field that's like
dominated by men I'm like there's a lot
of that Asian culture too I think that
was probably one of the bigger reasons
my parents and I got into a fight a lot
he goes they always said this don't you
see how you make me look and I got yes
shaving the yeah at a certain age I was
just like why the [ __ ] do you care about
other people and not about your own
family could you yeah that's weird about
how I feel and how you make me feel by
what you say versus what these other
[ __ ] people they'll die who the [ __ ]
cares
but I'm here even as a little kid my
mom's like you can't be dressed like
that like I've really five she's like
where do people to think of me
[Laughter]
I'm dirty
no what no should let you can't look
dirty because they're gonna it's gonna
come back to me and like what you doing
this no like if you eat and you spill
something or you know how kids just like
to play in the grass and then you have
like grass stains or whatever that's how
I'm always with me all the time too oh
no you're continuing the tradition
that's awesome cereal recently that [ __ ]
was crazy you know Casey do that on
purpose you want to do it ASMR and like
stop nothing like listening to slurping
and chewing food dude though no but
going back on this email I do tell Isaac
like you know your your representation
of me when you're out in public because
then I see him like he's been having
issues like anger issues in school and
so I'm like that's when I applied to
that not really like how he looked yeah
but just it's hard to tell kids hey you
just need to control your anger you just
give them the tools to control it you'd
like to give them like like a bat that
countertenors a rope chapter 10 the
freestream
I don't work because kids it's like it's
like trying to it's just tell the kid
just figure it out you you you're smart
enough just control yourself for sure we
talked to him and then we're also doing
the meditation like okay whenever you're
feeling like you're about to cuz he does
this thing where he for some reason he
like kind of go crazy she's like ah yeah
a little bit like when he gets
frustrated with his homework you like
rip it up or he'll go like this and I'm
like okay just tap into the meditating
that we've been doing no not not he's
too young for meditating put that [ __ ]
in to [ __ ] dance or some [ __ ] when he
gets angry [ __ ] Oh Mario you're the rain
and [ __ ] no shirt off yeah God do that
[ __ ] do this mother
as I try to give them tools that's cool
because my mom would just smack me in
the face and say control yourself but
that doesn't help yeah cuz I used to
break [ __ ] used to it like a year ago
the phone I hate that had that habit
though if I guess so I'm controlling I
had to break something pass I have to
break something it can't be this it
can't be like something soft like this
either it have to be something that
you're not supposed to break that you
have to obliterate it won't you just get
your fingers
I like that solution right yeah I got a
break like something's important to me
hey guys thanks for watching that last
episode did you love it
yes you did so don't forget to subscribe
this is first time you're here we've
uploaded every single day so don't miss
an upload now to watch more episodes
check them out ok
[Music]